I guess I have to be the one to tell you
[Music]
you're dead the city we're fighting over
scraps here I've seen it raised by fire
shaken by quakes whatever you do in my
city I will hear about it
Seattle is firmly under my control
you're obviously new to this whole
existence but truth is most of you types
won't even make it a whole year so you
probably figured out that you need to
drink blood you can't just do whatever
you want
cities are carved up by political
factions never tell anyone about what
you are see vampires are extremely
territorial unwittingly poached in
someone's territory and suddenly flesh
we have one rule you don't break the
masquerade
welcome to the first day of the rest of
your death having fun yet
I'm happy to see you accepted my
invitation all I need you to do is to
find a thin blood by the name of slug
he's in hiding but the Nosferatu most
likely know where he is once you find
slug all you have to do is purchase some
information off of it feel free to use
whatever methods are needed to get him
to comply I assume your handlers have
sent you to find our smelly friend you
can find slug under the freeway or in a
place the locals call the jungle he's
smart enough to hide among the homeless
down there but not quite smart enough to
do it well talk to him about coming to
see us and no one needs to know well let
you keep anything you've been promised
from whoever sent you to me but you'll
want to watch yourself lots of unsavory
animals in the jungle I don't know you
that's a good start slug is a coward but
he survived this long on his own so he's
bound to be a handful
is also not the only one you'll need to
look out for
and needed to get it well let you keep
anything you've been promised
just let me go come on just let me leave
[Music]